We are teaching people how to pray.
>> And every time they pray, you get to
share in that reward. And when they
teach their children and their
children's children
the reward continues. Every Fajr Dhuhr
Asr
>> Maghrib Isha Every recitation for just
£100 [music]
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn how to pray salah. Donate
today.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says in the Quran, "Do not ever think
that Allah is unaware of what the
evildoers do. He only delays them for a
day that their eyes will look in
horror." Well, their eyes are looking in
horror in the sky while those Iranian
missiles are dropping on them. And while
their Iron Dome fails them, if not
anything, misses those missiles costing
millions of pounds to get a few drones
that are 35,000 pounds. And if not, the
Iron Dome attacks itself.
Which
I guess I guess it's crazier. So,
subhanallah, here is an analysis,
brothers and sisters, that Israel, Tel
Aviv, is looking like Gaza. Okay? And
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala subhanahu wa
ta'ala will put the fear in their
hearts. Okay? We don't want any innocent
person. Well, no, they're not our
teachers.
I don't get happy when if I was to hear
innocent Israelis, innocent children,
yes? Okay, even though
they're evil, they they they are happy,
they want them to be massacred, but
they're not our teachers. If I was happy
about innocent Israeli children, women,
men who call for the genocide in Gaza,
if I was happy saying, "No, good,
because you guys do the same." I'll be
as bad as them.
I don't want them. They want that for
the Gazans
I don't want that for them. And I
believe the Gazans don't want that for
them. Here is an analysis, subhanallah,
of um
this individual which if I'm not
mistaken,
ex-US colonel ex-US colonel claims that
Israel is in big problem. And they're
giving 5 years sentences to anybody that
records the destruction in Tel Aviv.
Well, let's hear for himself.
I saw video this morning, real video,
not CNN, though they have been better,
but real video, real video out of
Israel. They are getting absolutely
pummeled.
>> That was to be my next question. How
badly is Israel getting pummeled? And
where is Netanyahu? I think he's on
plane 90% of the time. He's flying
around, he's flying around the
Mediterranean. I understood he was on a
private jet coming into Mar-a-Lago to
talk to Trump. I don't know if that's
true or not, but my source is pretty
good. He's staying out of frame as best
he can because he knows that he is
number one target.
How badly are the Iranians um damaging
Tel Aviv? Very badly, very badly. And it
is relentless. It's not a fuselage, it's
relentless and increasingly and in the
latter stages of this 15-minute video,
you could see that fewer and fewer air
defense missiles were going up and at
the end of it, in the last 60 seconds,
which is a long time, judge, if you're
under under fire, there were no Israeli
missiles going up. The Iranian missiles
were just getting in.
Well,
well,
it's all being lied about, of course.
You you can't get this out You can't
even get it out of Al Jazeera or Al
Arabiya. They they're not allowed to
film this sort of thing because he's got
a wrapped down tight ban on anybody
coming in there and making film other
than his own propaganda. The only
democracy in the Middle East. Let's see
the footages
from the sky, on the ground for those
who have managed to record it somehow it
got leaked. Here is some footages of the
cluster bombs that Iran is using now
with the ballistic missiles that turn
into 20, 30, 40 cluster bombs. As-salamu
alaykum that can cause real damage.
Oh Oh my god.
>> Open. Open. Open.
If you look Oh my god.
I look over That's one. Listen Here,
watch it. Another one.
OH MY GOD.
OH MY GOD. YO. YO.
>> [screaming]
>> YO!
YO!
NO WAY! OH my god! NO WAY! UH
yes way. Uh not no way, yes way. Uh
sadly, you know, you start problems, you
start fights, you try to attack uh
massacre 158
innocent Iranian girls, children, you
want to protect the Iranian woman, uh
you either uh the your flipping
pedophiles are either raping them in the
Peter Islands, Epstein Islands. Yes, you
Zionist bastards, yes, are raping those
American girls there to blackmail the
elite to tell them that look, we're
going to we're going to be raping the
American girls
uh to blackmail the elite so they can be
going to war with Iran Iran and bomb
innocent girls in school. Yes, that's
how much they care about the girls.
NO WAY!
OH MY GOD! OH my god!
Holy [__]
Oh my god!
OH MY GOD!
>> [screaming]
>> OH MY GOD!
YO!
>> [snorts]
>> OH!
Oh my god!
That's [__] It actually hit right
here.
Oh my god, that He's actually in denial.
He's actually shocked. Like he actually
would believe he had the real certainty
belief that this can't happen to us.
Like the guy is in absolute shock. Like
he's like It's like It's like me
s- beating a family
and then when they come to beat me up,
I'm like, "No, no, no way. You guys are
doing this? No way. Why are you doing
this to me?" It's like
Are you stupid?
You've attacked the innocent. They're
coming back for you. I would Like he's
in denial. No, no way. Oh crap. How
could this happen to me? Well, they are
cheap people, strange people, man. Let's
get another another angle.
But, I'll get from TRT. This is another
one they won't show you. Let's
watch another one.
There you go. You think you're going to
get away with the blood of 70,000
people? Yes?
And again, yeah, and bear in mind
they are using the Israelis as their own
people as human shields. Their Iron
Domes are flying from inside Israel
cities. And here's a
the press to you. I don't know which
where she's from, but yeah, let's see.
I am in Holon right now. Uh one of the
sites that had a direct Iranian
ballistic missile hit to it. Uh let me
just show you the buildings right now.
Absolutely decimated. You can just see
the impact this missile had. I mean,
this entire floor collapsed right in the
middle, down the entire apartment
building. These are residential
buildings.
Uh we have some crews, of course, on
scene as well. You can just see Look at
that. All the air conditioning units
just coming out of the building.
Debris everywhere. We're going to have
more updates on ILTV.
Well, there you go. There you go. That's
And you know, she's showing what's
happening. But, don't forget what's
happening in Gaza. Sadly, it's what And
again, we're not I'm not condoning
anything.
Uh we're morally consistent, not
strategically consistent. That I do not
wish any innocent person to be harmed,
no matter how much of these innocent
Israelis needing 90-plus percent of them
uh want Gaza to be demolished. They are
pro-genocidal maniacs. Yes?
They teach this to their children, to
the women, to the adults. They are
calling for that, but I would never do
the same cuz it would make me no
different to them. Breaking news. This
is Tel Aviv today after barrage of
missiles from Iran came through last
night. The attacks continue today with
fewer missiles, but many more drones
that America and Israel cannot stop.
Today Iran launched a new generation
missile and Iranian missiles and drones
are dominating the Israeli skies.
An Iranian drone struck a US base in
Kuwait damaging key US facilities and 3
hours ago the IRGC Navy hit the USS
Abraham Lincoln and the carrier
retreated. And last but not least, the
Iron Dome completely failing or running
out of ammunition, here is what the
night sky looked like in Israel.
And there you go, guys. Subhan Allah.
Do you think Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala is
just going to let them get away?
How could you live in that fear? You've
stolen the lands of these people.
Promised land, whatever it is for that
matter. Imagine the Quran gives us a
promised land and Muslims go there and
justify it.
There'll be uproar. These people are the
most evil, satanic people and their
double standards and hypocrisy is
exposed every single day.
Now Israel is looking like Gaza.
Not that we want that because we don't
want that for anybody.
But that is a reality of war and that is
exactly what's going on. You went and
bombed 150, 168 Iranian girls.
Yes?
Innocent
girls
massacred.
You know the target you hit, and you
know what you're doing. You hit the
civilians on purpose to put pressure.
It's backfired cuz Iranians are now more
adamant. They've put the flags of martyr
them up.
Yes?
So, and you've underestimated them. And
like Professor Young Young said, that
you're going to lose this war.
You are going to lose this war. And
Allah is going to humiliate you. Okay?
You pedo island
you're in in your pedo island where you
are committing satanic stuff.
Satanic rituals.
Subhanallah.
Look how Allah dropped the mask in one
go.
And how he exposed you guys.
That's all I have to say to my sisters.
Inshallah, may Allah bless and preserve
you guys. Till next time. As-salamu
alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.